SHIRLEY GAW: Hi.
My name is Shirley, and I'm a
software engineer working in
the Paris office, and I'm on
the YouTube Data API team.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: And I'm
Philipp Pfeiffenberger.
I'm also a software engineer
working in the Paris office,
and I'm working on the semantic
annotation of YouTube videos.
SHIRLEY GAW: So in this session,
I'd like to go over
how I taught YouTube that my
baby is cute, but more
generally, how you as a content
creator can improve
semantic annotations for your
videos and channels.
And also, how you as application
developers can
discover content on YouTube
based on Freebase topics.
So Philipp's team's been working
on automatically
annotating resources such as
videos and channels with
Freebase topics.
Now, if you're not familiar with
Freebase, it's an open,
crowd-sourced Knowledge Graph
where nodes corresponds to
real world things-- so for
example, a person or a place
or a song--
and each of these nodes
has a unique ID.
So in the latest version of the
YouTube Data API, you can
actually look up, for example,
a YouTube video and see what
Freebase topics have
been automatically
associated with it.
Furthermore, you can supply a
Freebase topic ID and see what
YouTube resources are related
to that topic.
So in the session, I'm going to
talk about why you should
care about the quality of these
video annotations--
so how it's being used, and also
how you can improve the
quality of the annotations
for your content.
Philipp will go into my specific
example explaining
how we arrive at those video
annotations and then other
signals that go into the
annotations process.
Understanding that, we'll go
back to my first example and
explain how I was able to
improve the annotations.
And then, we'll walk through
an integration between the
Freebase API for getting
related topics--
getting topics in general,
actually--
and the YouTube Data API to
find content on YouTube.
And then finally, Philipp's
going to talk about work that
his team's been doing that will
give you more Freebase
annotations, and hopefully
we'll see it in
the API real soon.
So why should you care about
the quality of video
annotations?
Well actually, at YouTube, this
is one of the signals we
use for surfacing content
and organizing it.
So for example, if you're
looking at the Home page, it's
one of the signals that we use
for featuring content--
also when you do search and
some special features.
Also specifically, we're using
it as a signal in our video
and channel recommendations, and
this is how some external
partners have been using
it in the Topics API.
So for example, Interesante is
focused on Latino users and
culturally-relevant content
for those users.
So they look in Freebase, find
related topics for things that
people are interested in, find
content on YouTube, and then
suggest that to their users as
things that they can add in
their collections.
Showyou is more general,
in that it's
showing internet videos.
And when you're watching
something in the latest iPhone
app, it'll show you the topic it
thinks the video is about.
It's using the Topics API
as one of the signals.
And then from there, it can
suggest other internet videos
related to that topic.
Seevl is actually specializing
in music recommendation.
So say your friend likes
an obscure band.
If you're using the YouTube
data as your music source,
then you can actually find
more YouTube videos
related to that band.
So now that you understand why
video annotations and quality
video annotations are important
for content, let's
go into my favorite example.
So this is my daughter.
And if you're a human being,
what would you say
this video is about?
Be nice.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Self-discovery.
SHIRLEY GAW: Self-discovery as
kind of a step in development.
AUDIENCE: I'd say it's
about mirrors.
SHIRLEY GAW: Mirrors.
So you can talk about some
things in the scene,
particular people in the
scene, describing
what you see there.
What does YouTube think
of this video?
So actually, we only
expose this in the
Topics API for now.
So you don't see
it on the site.
What you do is make an HTTP GET
request to googleapis.com.
The latest version of YouTube.
We look at the videos
collection for a
specific video ID.
And now, we say that we're
interested in the video
annotations by saying in the
response that we want
part="topicDetails."
So what did YouTube you think
this video was about?
There's no green, which means
it doesn't think anything
about my video.
Of course, working on the Topics
API, that's clearly not
good enough for the mother.
So I uploaded a second version
of this video, and I made sure
that there were some high
quality annotations.
I did a few tweaks and a
little search engine
optimization, which I'll
discuss later.
But now, when we query
this new video, it's
the exact same content.
But now, we get two topics,
which are shown in green.
We can go to Freebase, append
the Freebase ID, and you can
see the first thing.
The first topic is that
it's about an infant.
The second topic, cuteness.
I like to conclude
that I taught
YouTube my baby is cute.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Thanks, Shirley.
So we've received a lot of
questions from developers--
exactly how videos are
annotated and how the
annotations that we export for
videos should be interpreted.
In order to shed some light onto
those questions, I want
to walk through the annotation
process using
a few example cases.
Well, before we can start
annotating anything, we want
to look at what kind of data
we have available for the
annotation process.
We want to list these in the
order of their availability.
So first and foremost, we
have the text metadata.
At the time of upload, the
uploader will insert some
text-- a title, description,
and so on--
and we have this immediately
available.
A few minutes after upload,
we'll have extracted some
audiovisual features that we can
use to classify the video.
And finally, if the video's
popular enough, there may be
some context, both on the open
internet and on YouTube, that
we can help to further
guide annotation.
So I want to illustrate these
with one example video for
each data type.
But as I do this, we should
keep in mind that for your
average YouTube video, we
try to make use of all
three types of data.
I want to start with Shirley's
video, which was just uploaded
and only has text metadata to
work with at this point.
So I'm going to walk through the
annotation process using
Shirley's video, the text, and
the entities as an example.
And as I do this, you should
keep in mind that also for the
other data sources,
the process I walk
through is the same.
So we know that the
text metadata is
provided by the uploader.
It includes title, description,
any tags that the
uploader included
at that time.
And we also know that text and
concepts have a many-to-many
association.
That is, text is ambiguous.
The concept of infant can be
communicated by the word
"baby," by the word "infant," by
the word "toddler," so on.
And likewise, the word "baby"
without any sort of context
can refer to a Justin Bieber
song, can refer to an infant,
can refer to a number
of other things.
For that reason, we depend on
the text to be consistent to
allow us to correctly
dereference what concepts are
mentioned therein.
Now, even though we depend on
the uploader to give us this
text metadata and we have to
correlate this with other data
sources, it's really valuable,
because it's available to us
immediately.
So now, to walk through
the process.
I'm not sure why it's
not showing up.
OK, we're back.
Sorry about that.
All right, so we have
some text metadata.
And luckily, we have enough of
it to correctly dereference
all the concepts within it.
From Shirley's video, her
description, and her title, we
were able to extract the
concepts of mother, daughter,
infant, mirror, and so on.
Now, you see that some of
these are shown in bold.
That's because we assign a score
to each concept based on
its prevalence in
the metadata.
For this simplified example,
I'm simply giving twice the
score for any entities that
show up in the title.
So now, we have some entities.
We have some weighting.
But we can't quite go ahead and
say infant and mirror are
what this video's about
because they
showed up in the title.
In order to figure out what the
central entities for the
video are, we use links
between concepts.
We extract these from the open
internet, where we learned
that mother and daughter,
daughter and infant, infant
and cute tend to co-occur, and
we can build a support graph
between these concepts.
So now, we have weighted
entities.
We have a support graph.
How do we figure out
which entities are
central to the video?
That's where we go to scoring
and thresholding.
So first, we give each entity
one point simply for existing,
two points for existing in the
title in this example.
And then, we give one additional
point for each
entity that links
to that entity.
So infant gets three more
points, because three other
entities link to it.
Mirror gets one more point.
And after applying some
thresholding, we determine
that the central entities
for this video
are infant and cute.
Now, that's all fair and
well when we have
really good text metadata.
But we're not always that
lucky, especially in
the world of gaming.
Oftentimes, we get gaming
videos that mention
characters, that mention
levels, but
don't mention the game.
If you look at the video on the
right, you see "Book raid
on the nether!
Working Draft." If you're a
human that plays games, you
know it's Minecraft.
But looking just at the
metadata, you're kind of lost.
Luckily, this is
a gaming video.
And luckily, for gaming videos,
we're guaranteed
predictable lighting
conditions.
And we're also guaranteed
some static features--
status bar, fonts, and
so on and so forth--
so we can train classifiers to
help us identify these games.
Now, this is great for games,
but it's usefulness rapidly
decays when you generalize
to the general
content we have on YouTube.
If, for example, I were
a really great set of
classifiers, and I told you that
some video featured a man
in a top hat with a beard, a man
with a t-shirt, flip flops
in a mall, you wouldn't be able
to deduce that this might
be a modern-day parody involving
Abraham Lincoln.
Those types of nuances are lost
when you use classifiers.
However, because this is
available just minutes after
upload and applicable for some
verticals, it remains in
active development for us.
But sometimes we don't even have
audiovisual features to
work with or no classifiers
to match.
So in the case where we have a
video that lacks both good
metadata and distinct
audiovisual feature--
like the video on the right
titled "Me at the zoo"--
if we had a good classifier, we
might get "elephant" and we
might get "man." That's
about it.
However, if we look at the
context of the video--
that is, the discussions going
on in the comments, the web
pages that it's embedded in and
what those web pages are
about, and the overall
user engagement--
then we can try to figure
out what is
notable about this video.
And we can figure out that it's
notable because Jawed
Karim is in it, and he's one of
the co-founders of YouTube,
and this was the first video
ever uploaded to YouTube.
Now, individually, all of these
signals are hideously
noisy, as you can imagine.
But on the aggregate, once you
have enough of them, they
become really powerful for
really popular videos that we
otherwise don't know
much about.
Now, you can't quite rely on
this as uploaders, because you
probably won't have every video
reach 10 million views.
But if you're consumers of the
API, you can deduce from this
that a video with a lot of views
is probably going to
have more confident annotations
than a video with
just a handful of views.
So now that we know how
annotations work, I'm going to
give it back to Shirley, who's
going to show us what she did
on her second upload to get
better annotations.
SHIRLEY GAW: So let's
talk about my
favorite YouTube not-star.
If you recall from the beginning
of the session, I
had two versions of the
exact same video.
The first version had no
annotations, and the second
version had two annotations.
Now, what happened in between?
The first thing to recall is
that, for some reason, this
video is not as popular
as I would expect.
And we don't have any
blogosphere love and no
comments, so that means
we can't use the
video context signal.
Likewise, we don't have any
audiovisual feature matching,
so in this particular case,
we're relying entirely on
video metadata.
So if we're doing that,
then we need to have
the video be public.
Otherwise, it's not
caught by our
video annotations pipeline.
Also, if we're relying on text
metadata, that text metadata
should say something.
So the title should actually
be a concise description of
the content of the video, and we
should be adding supporting
text and tags.
So the second version of video
is the same content.
But it's a public video, and
we're adding metadata to
support what we say that
the video is about.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: So I've
made a few references to
centrality and central
annotations without really
defining what it is, and that's
because it's a very
narrow but powerful concept.
We consider a video's
annotations to be central if
these applications
are complete--
that is, given the annotations,
you can figure
out what the video is about--
if they're specific--
that is, if you can't replace
any of these entities with a
more specific entity that still
refers to the same concept--
and if they're compact--
that is, if you can't remove
any of these entities and
still completely describe
the video.
For example, if we had a video
of this talk and we wanted to
annotate it, you would likely
choose the entities "semantic
annotation," "Google I/O 2013,"
and "YouTube API,"
because these would be
complete-- you know what the
video's about--
specific-- we can't
find anything more
specific for any of them--
and compact.
You can't really remove any of
them and still understand what
it's about.
However, if we had a single
entity for this talk in
Freebase, you would gladly
remove all three of these and
replace them with that one
entity, because it would still
be complete, specific, and
definitely compact.
You could use Freebase to still
figure out that this was
a talk at Google I/O, this was
about YouTube API, and so on.
A layman's way that we've kind
of put this into words is an
annotation is likely to be
part of a set of central
annotations if you would include
the name of the entity
in a one sentence description
of the video.
And separately, if you are
curating a YouTube channel
about this topic, would you
choose this video as a
canonical example about
that entity?
If you answer both of those
questions as yes
independently, then this is
likely an entity that's part
of the central set
of annotations.
It follows then that relevant
is not central.
A video of this talk annotated
with an entity for Moscone
Center, that entity would not
be part of a central set of
annotations, because we can
remove it and still
describe the talk.
And also, of course, related
is not central.
Android API would not be part
of a central set of
annotations.
So what does that mean
for developers?
Well, it means that for your
average YouTube video, you can
expect one to three very
specific, very narrow
annotations that should
completely describe the video.
Even though these are very
specific and narrow, you can
use the structured data in
Freebase, which is available
as a downloadable data dump, to
get more information about
these entities.
Also, you should know that
more popular videos will
probably have more confidence
in annotations, because we
have more signals to help
us annotate them.
And if you're an uploader, you
should use precise titles and
cohesive descriptions that talk
about what the video's
about to help us give you the
correct entities from the
start and so that the other
signals simply dovetail those
correct entities we
started from.
So not just to talk about what
you can do with these narrow
entities, but I actually kind
of want to show you what is
possible with the central
annotations
that we have today.
I'm not going to talk about what
the demo does before I go
into it, but you should
know that this is not
a rules-based demo.
That is, it's agnostic about
what kind of entity I'm
currying for, and it's about
maybe 60 lines of Python.
So say, for example, I want to
explore origami on YouTube.
I don't know what origami's
about except it's about
folding paper, but I
want to learn more.
So I look up the entity
on Freebase.
And how are videos categorized
if I use entities?
Well, it turns out that origami
on YouTube tends to be
different shapes of organisms,
and I can use this to learn
how to fold origami.
So I can start learning
folding roses, cats.
And after I've spent enough time
indoors folding origami,
I want to go outside and
travel a little bit.
So I want to look up
what do we have
about travel on YouTube.
Probably videos categorized
into countries and cities.
And sure enough, we have travel
videos about different
countries and different
cities and so on.
After a lot of traveling and
walking and sightseeing, I'm
probably hungry.
I want to check out some
local cuisine.
So I look up what videos we have
about cuisine on YouTube,
how we can structure those.
And probably, we're going to see
different ingredients and
different types of food.
So this is actually relatively
straightforward.
All I'm doing is I'm searching
for 100 videos that were
centrally annotated
with origami.
And then, I take all of the
other entities that those
videos were annotated with, and
I use Freebase to look up
their notable types.
I then create clusters
of notable types.
Say, for example, I had a video
annotated with origami
and cat, another one
origami and bat.
Cat and Bat would fall into the
canonical type of organism.
And then, I choose the largest
set of notable types, and then
I present the entities along
with the videos that were
annotated with them.
So I'm going to give it back
to Shirley, who's going to
walk us through the API calls
that were made behind the
scenes to make this happen.
SHIRLEY GAW: So just to
summarize, we're fetching
content on YouTube based on a
specific Freebase topic ID.
That's selected from
the user using the
Freebase suggestion widget.
Once we have a topic ID, we
can discover content on
YouTube using universal
search.
So for YouTube, that means
that we can find videos,
channels, and playlists.
In this particular case, we're
interested only in the videos.
So suppose that the
user selected
origami, like shown earlier.
Then, we want to find content on
YouTube related to origami,
and we get a bunch of videos--
100 in this case.
Now, we want to see, are
these videos about
more than just origami?
We want to find what are the
other central topics.
So we've go to the video's
list service, find those
central topics, and then look
up the notable types and
cluster based on that, which is
the coloring that he showed
in the demo.
So first of all, Freebase
suggestion widget.
This is just something that
you can find going to this
website, and they'll give you
instructions for embedding it
in your web page.
Users type in text their
suggested entries.
Now, you get a Freebase
machine ID.
Let's switch over
to API Explorer.
So this is a nice way of being
able to play with Google APIs
for different products.
So developers.googl
e.com/apis-explorer.
You select the YouTube Data
API, so the latest public
version of our Data API.
You'll see these are different
resources and operations on
those resources.
In this case, we want to
discover content on YouTube
related to a specific topic.
And then, once we find those
videos that we're interested
in, let's get more information
about them
through videos list.
So let's start off with finding
content on YouTube.
The nice thing about the API
Explorer is that it explains
what all the different
parameters are using this text
on the right.
And you can see what all of
them possibly are and how
they're used.
And then, if it's in red,
it means it's a required
parameter for the request.
Now, I've pre-filled
out this form.
And recall the user selected a
specific suggested topic ID,
topic, and then we get the
Freebase machine ID.
Oops, that's a bit overkill.
We say we want to find videos,
type="video" on
this specific topic.
I'm using origami
as the example.
And we want the IDs of the
resources, and for this demo,
I'm going to show you the
metadata as well.
Now, Philipp's demo uses 100
videos and fetches that.
In the case of the API, we can
only get 50 at a time, so
we're going to have to do two
calls to get 100 videos.
I'm going to execute
this request again.
You'll see here this is the HTTP
GET request that you need
to make, and it pretty-prints
the format of the results--
so different origami videos.
We can then select
these video IDs.
If you recall, we have videos
related to a specific topic.
Now, we're going to see
what other essential
annotations there are.
So I have preselected three of
these results, and we go to
the videos list service up here,
GET just like in the
example I showed before
with the baby.
In this case though, I'm just
filling it out in a form in
the API Explorer.
So part="topicDetials."
Comma-separated video IDs here.
Execute the request.
And you see in the response that
some videos have not just
origami as a central topic,
but they have other topics
associated with them as well.
Now to see what these topics
are, we can use the Freebase
Search API.
So Freebase has another service
to be able to play
with filters.
So
api-examples.freebaseapps.com.
I pre-filled in this particular
Freebase machine ID.
And you can see in the request
that this video was actually
also about an octopus, so
origami octopus, and that its
notable type is organism.
So we can group videos that
are about organisms.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: Cool.
So what does this tell us,
except that it's possible to
build topic-agnostic
applications?
Well, even though these entities
are really specific
and really narrow, you can
use Freebase to get more
information about each
of the entities we
annotate a video with.
Also, if you're building
an application
that's domain specific--
say, for example,
a movie site--
you can use Freebase to look up
the director of a movie, to
look up actors in a movie, and
then to cluster videos based
on whether there are interviews,
trailers, and so
on and so forth.
And of course, if you think this
is really cool and you
want to play with it more, we've
got a Codelab on Friday
where both Shirley and
I will be TAing.
And we'll guarantee you that if
you go there, you're going
to walk away with a working app
that works with the Topics
API and the Freebase API.
And it's movies-based,
so it's pretty cool.
OK, so we know we have some
decent annotations that we can
do some cool stuff with, but
our work is far from over.
We take quality really
seriously, and we use human
evaluations to assess the
centrality of entities.
We take raters, knowing their
language, pairing them with
the language of the video, and
ask them, given a video, is
the entity off-topic, relevant,
or central?
And doing this, we've been able
to reduce the number of
off-topic annotations over the
past year while maintaining
coverage across the
YouTube corpus.
Now aside from raters, we
depend on your feedback.
So if you see off-topic
annotations, or you see
systematic patterns of off-topic
annotations, please
file a ticket using
gdata-issues.
If you have more general
questions about annotations,
you can reach out via
YouTubeDev, and we'll get them
answered for you.
So there are some classes of
problems that are pretty
nefarious that we're battling
that I want to highlight for
just a second.
Common knowledge
is one of them.
We assume that everyone knows
what a daughter is, what a
mother is, what a baby is.
And therefore, we don't put the
stuff on Wikipedia to a
great extent.
So for these really common
concepts, the machine
repositories of knowledge that
we have are actually pretty
barren, which makes it more
difficult for us to annotate
these common concepts.
Similarly, new topics.
When "Harlem Shake" first got
popular, we happily annotated
the video with "Harlem Shake,
a dance introduced
in 1981." Not right.
After a week and a few days,
we had an entity for Harlem
Shake the internet meme, but
that's not good enough in a
world where memes tend to rise
and fade within days,
Also, local facts.
If you upload a video simply
entitled "Hiro's Sushi
Restaurant," we're going to
have a really hard time
figuring out which Hiro's
Sushi restaurant it is,
because there are thousands
across the country.
However, in this case, it
was titled "Hiro's Sushi
Restaurant--
Sedona, Arizona." So we can
probably use this to figure
out which restaurant was
actually mentioned, assuming
we have an entity for this
restaurant in Freebase.
Lastly, overlapping names in
the same concept space are
pretty tricky.
One of our partners, seevl,
pointed out to us that there
was a little-known band called
Nirvana that we annotated
wrong all the time.
And we were lost, because we
know Nirvana really well.
We grew up with Nirvana.
And it turns out that there's
a 1970s British psychedelic
band called Nirvana that we just
didn't annotate when we
really should have.
Again, with more metadata,
we can do a better job at
disambiguation.
If we have a video entitled
"Nirvana--
In Bloom," which is one of their
songs from the 1990s
band, we can get the right
band without a problem.
But if we have "Nirvana--
Live in Bristol," and nothing
else, and it's the 1970s band,
we're going to guess that's it
the 1990s band, because it's a
safer guess without any
other information.
And we'll get it wrong
in that case.
So aside from fixing bugs, which
is always fun, there's
some really exciting stuff that
I'm working on right now
that I'm really excited
about getting into.
One of them is relevant
annotations.
So we've heard the cries for
more entities per video, and
we're addressing it using
relevant annotations.
So just like central
annotations, relevant
applications are their own
class of annotations.
They're entities that are
relevant to the video and
would be of interest to someone
watching the video.
So, for example, in Shirley's
video, most likely "mirror"
would be relevant, at least.
Likewise, if we had a video of
a live concert, the location
of the concert, band members
that are featured in the
video, would also be relevant.
Now, relevant is not related.
A different band in the same
genre would not be relevant.
Likewise, relevant is
not low confidence
or low quality central.
It's its own distinct class of
annotations that you can use
knowing that they're relevant.
Similarly, we'll be exposing a
taxonomy of annotations that
we've established internally.
At this point, if we had a video
of a tennis match, we'd
be happy annotating with the
names of the tennis players,
the name of the tournament,
and if we have any other
information, maybe the year of
the tournament and so on.
However, even though you can get
the information about it
that these are tennis players
and it's about tennis from
Freebase, we want to offload
some of that by exploiting
taxonomy and telling you
explicitly this is a video
about tennis, about racquet
sports, and about sports.
So to kind of drive this home
a little bit, I took a
screenshot of a video
on the right.
"DVF (through Glass)." DVF
stands for Diane Von
Furstenberg.
And I want to ask you, looking
at this video, what do you
think would be the central
entities, relevant entities,
and taxonomy entities?
Any brave takers?
AUDIENCE: Fashion Week.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Fashion Week.
For central, relevant,
or taxonomy?
Relevant?
OK.
Anyone else for central
or taxonomy?
AUDIENCE: Glass.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: Glass.
Very good.
For central, I'm guessing?
Anyone else?
Going once, going twice.
SHIRLEY GAW: Heard something
in the audience.
AUDIENCE: Events.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Events.
For relevant?
AUDIENCE: For taxonomy.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Yeah, that could be.
OK.
So for this example, which I
didn't actually annotate,
central, we actually
annotated.
And we had Google Glass and
Diane Von Furstenberg.
Relevant would be New York
Fashion Week, because this is
where this video was shot.
And then taxonomy, we'd probably
put it into gadgets
and technology, because it's
primarily about Google Glass.
But similarly, events probably
could also fall into the
taxonomy classification.
So hopefully, this answered your
questions and maybe even
raised some new ones that
we would love to
hear at this point.
[APPLAUSE]
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Thank you.
SHIRLEY GAW: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I was curious
about Minecraft example.
So how do you seed your data
for that and sort of how
expansive that?
So would you have every game
ever made in there?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
I wish.
AUDIENCE: Or are you
specifically listing which
things you care about?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: I
wish we had every game
ever made in there.
That would be a dream of mine.
We've got some things that
we're classifying for.
I can't disclose the list of
things, because it's not very
well defined.
But it's something that we're
expanding to increase coverage
on, because it was a big hit in
the first iteration, and we
definitely want to
go further on it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Lek Lek Mai from
Yale University.
And we have a lot of videos that
have topics that are not
covered in Freebase, but we
have our own semantic
repository.
So what you would you suggest
for the best way of connecting
all that up?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: That's
a good question.
I would reach out maybe to
someone on the Knowledge team.
SHIRLEY GAW: Freebase has
a session here too.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: Yeah.
Definitely reach out to
the folks on Freebase.
And people working in Knowledge
in general, I think,
would be really great
contacts for that.
Regrettably, we're only
consumers of these knowledge
repositories, and we don't
get to fully administer
what goes onto them.
SHIRLEY GAW: But this does come
up as a sparseness in the
Knowledge Graph for specific
use cases, and one of the
things to do is being able to
contribute to that graph.
But since you've already had
something more developed, you
might want to just directly
ask Freebase how you can
contribute that information.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Could I ask one more
quick question?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Of course.
AUDIENCE: So you talked about
terms and vocabularies that
you're using.
And just wanted to ask, have you
looked at other services
that have vocabularies in
broader terms and narrower
terms, like the Getty
Vocabulary, for example, and
utilizing those?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
No, I have not.
That sounds really interesting
though.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Maybe after the session.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Yeah, definitely.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I'm Jarom McDonald.
I'm from Brigham Young
University.
One question that I had--
and you may have quickly
glossed over it.
But if you have any further
details, it'd be really
interesting.
Other types of YouTube
annotations, the interactive
clicks and the questions that
are in and so forth are able
to link temporally and spatial
to your video, whereas it
looks like a lot of the things
you can do with the Topics API
is just for the video
as a whole.
And do you see any ability,
either now or eventually, to
be able to link topics to
individual temporal moments in
the video or spatial
areas of the video?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: That's
a really good idea.
To be honest, at this point, we
really want to get it right
for the video as a whole.
But having that finer
granularity would definitely
be an asset.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SHIRLEY GAW: Thanks for
the suggestion.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
So you guys were talking about
the text metadata for a little
while and how that's kind of
like the first line of defense
since you have it earliest.
And maybe I just missed it, but
do you guys also work with
comments and user data
afterwards as that comes in?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER:
Yes, exactly.
So that's part of the context
of the video.
So we look at the comments of
the video, and we look at all
the web pages where
the video appears.
And then, we also extract
concepts from the comments and
from the web pages and
try to figure, OK,
well, what's the overlap?
And sometimes, there
can be some pretty
funny stuff that happens.
When I was first playing with
this, there was a video of
"Another One Bites the Dust,"
and one of the entities that
kept coming up was
Kim Jong-il.
And I'm like, why is that?
And it turns out that when Kim
Jong-il passed away, in the
forums, people kept embedding
this video.
So individually, these sources
you can kind of forget about.
But again, once you have enough
of them, and once you
have enough data, you can see
what kind of things emerge
from them after doing
some filtering.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was wondering if you also did
speech recognition on the
video themselves to get
extra text from that.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: That's
a good question.
So we've looked at a
number of things--
speech recognition,
transcripts, and
so on and so forth.
And what tends to happen is if,
for example, you have a
video of the State of the
Union, and you do speech
recognition, you'll figure that
it's about the economy,
it's about jobs, it's about
current events, and
so on and so forth.
But you miss that it's the
State of the Union.
So it's something that we
might look in again as a
guiding signal.
But by itself, oftentimes what's
mentioned in the video
isn't necessarily what
the video is about,
except in a few cases.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So actually, that's kind of a
related question to what I
want to ask.
A lot of the stuff you're doing
seems to be where you
have an explicit word or
something like infant that
represents a concept,
and then you go and
find that in Freebase.
Is there, I guess, potential for
expansion using something
like WordNet, where if you don't
recognize maybe one of
the words in it, going and
finding something that might
be semantically related?
Or is that kind of too noisy,
I guess, for your approach?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: I'm
not familiar with WordNet.
But if there are words that we
don't recognize, we basically
just don't treat them.
Like if you have the name of
someone who we don't recognize
or who doesn't match any
sort of concept,
then that's just skipped.
SHIRLEY GAW: So WordNet, I'm
more familiar with that.
So it would be like synonyms and
antonyms of that concept.
I don't know if it's actually
a source for
the Knowledge Graph.
I can't specify for that one.
But in the case of the baby
video, it was really tough.
Because "baby" can be, as he
said, a Justin Bieber song.
So I did actually have to look
at a data dump from Freebase
and see what kinds of concepts
would support
the topic of baby.
So that's actually where
it would come in.
I don't know if WordNet would do
that for you, but you could
definitely use Freebase and
the related concepts to
support that.
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: And
we do support synonyms.
So for example, DVF would
probably dereference to Diane
Von Furstenberg, especially
with other
things supporting it.
So as long as you mention the
concepts in the video and you
help us dereference it to get
to the right ones, even if
there are synonyms, we try
to be smart enough
to allow for that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
You said in your simple case
that you were just weighting
title as double the
description.
Obviously, the world is
not a simple case.
What machine learning approaches
are you taking to
work out what these weightings
should be?
PHILIPP PFEIFFENBERGER: We
try a lot of things.
I can't speak to the actual
approaches that we use in
detail, but it's definitely
not the simple case.
I'm sorry, I can't answer
to more detail on that.
Anyone else?
OK.
Well, we'll also be hanging out
in the Sandbox for a few
minutes after this talk if you
have questions you want to ask
one on one.
And thank you for attending
this talk.
SHIRLEY GAW: Thanks very much.
[APPLAUSE]